We're here at a local shelter organizing for Martin Luther King Lend a Hand Project.
It's fitting with UPMC's corporate culture to volunteer and give back.
We are cleaning and we are trying to organize this.
I'm here today because I got a personal invitation from Michelle Obama...
...to dedicate some time today on Martin Luther King Day,...
...and it is my pleasure to be here at the Center for Victims.
Well, I'm actually new to UPMC.
I just started in October.
And when I saw the e-mail about Dignity and Respect...
...and the event on Martin Luther King Jr. Day that happened to be at my church...
I was really excited today about Martin Luther King Day and the inauguration fell on today,...
...and I wanted to do something besides just watching the inauguration on TV.
So I'm gonna be part of the UPMC family today,...
...lending a hand for Dignity and Respect.
We get the volunteers from UPMC to come out and participate with us.
And then from there, we bring our children and our family members,...
...and we have a great time together.